hi
uh yes um i'm rare
thankfully the room's emptied out a
little bit so i don't have to be quite
so nervous as i was beforehand
um i'm not gonna be showing you much
javascript code i'm afraid
so if you don't if you want to see a
little javascript code from toyota then
maybe you should go to the next room uh
i'm going to start about something that
we've been
working on as a company for the last
hundred years
and that is these things the cars okay
this is the one example which i thought
might impress javascript developers
uh most car companies
most equipment manufacturers most
people in the manufacturing world think
about this kind of thing which is
a product and this product doesn't have
anybody in it
if you can notice this you'll find that
most of the manufacturing
brochures for almost all equipment is
without people
because most original equipment
manufacturers
really care about the product and once
it goes outside of the factory it goes
to some distribution network
and then other people deal with
the people who drive these cars
and we can see a nice lady here in a car
that's good we can get
some people into cars we know that's
happening
in a dealership somewhere but we don't
really know much beyond that
now something about this picture you
might recognize
apart from the fact that you know we've
concentrated mostly
so far on the steering wheels and on the
dashboards and on the
the kind of engines and all that kind of
stuff but now we have these new things
in the cars
will allow us to uh serve the customer
a lot better and to really uh track
uh i mean understand what they're doing
in a better way
so this actually changes the game for
equipment manufacturers especially car
manufacturers
had an engine we've had steering wheels
we've had cars out on the road for a
long time
we haven't really known what's been
going on with them until fairly recently
we've got stuff
like the maps telemetry and what we want
to do is to be able to connect
the actual vehicles to the customers
that are driving those vehicles
and this is the beginning actually of a
culture shift
uh that was mentioned earlier on because
all of the systems inside of toyota all
of the systems inside of ford inside of
all of these equipment manufacturers
are all geared around producing stuff
they're not geared around
linking the people to the things that we
produce
and that's an opportunity for us
because you know as architects we we
benefit from opportunities and crises
and in this case we want to connect to
the cloud there's a lot of people out
there
we can't control that so all of the
on-site
um technology that we have that we've
been used to where there is a kind of
understood limit to how much activity
can go on those servers
suddenly becomes challenging so we have
an opportunity to go to the cloud
in manufacturing companies this is the
sort of split of things
as it were we have research and
development
we have supply chain we have
manufacturing and distribution
and what i want to discuss a little bit
is about the fact that
from a a software side
research and development looks like
software development to me
that's where we do all of our
development and that's bizarrely that's
not where
all the lean manufacturing stuff comes
from that's not where all the agile
stuff comes from actually
that that is a bit undiscovered like
most software development it's kind of
hard stuff
that has to be done and it's not
repeatable it's not
um simple so
that's where we are mostly on the left
research and development
but we've got supply chains now for us
and for us in this room supply chains
typically are things like
uh software as a service or software um
libraries like we use databases or
commercial libraries or
open source frameworks and then we have
manufacturing and manufacturing
in software in my opinion tends to be
around
the deployment the data center and the
data center is the thing which
was under pressure so we want to
potentially change that manufacturing
from a local data center to a cloud data
center and of course the distribution
from our side
is the internet or the network
now these guys do their exercises in the
morning so they're agile in that sense
but they're not changing things here
okay
what factories do is they repeat things
there we have the ideas in the software
world and factories
stamp them out go through a process
manage that process
make sure it's all repeatable make sure
it all works and
and that's good now
one of the problems with this is that
this this doesn't work very well if it's
not repeatable if it's not scalable
so if i have to go to each of these
factory workers and explain to them
how to build that car it's not good
we were taking up to two days
to deploy stuff in the in the existing
system
now i've got some drawings here of some
pictures on the left hand side this guy
is actually making bricks by hand
now that's fine artisanal work there for
this guy
everyone's happy you know he's got a job
but i would liken that perhaps
controversially to the technologies on
the right hand side
which are all the sort of stuff that we
were using before this
very manual so net xml we're using file
systems for our content
using subversion as our version
management system everything was kind of
manually deployed
it would take days to deploy something
not just to write it and test it and cue
it and all those kind of things
but to literally deploy it into
production
and then we're using monitoring tools on
a per
server basis like this scom stuff from
microsoft
we decided to change that to uh
to a different stack because we wanted
to what i would say is architect for the
factory we want to architect for
something which is scalable something
which is
automatable something which is simple
and visible for
to understand
and what we did there was we moved
basically everything
and we didn't we didn't do any
competition to say is.net
use this many cpu cycles or did is java
slightly more
i don't know uh more friendly by the way
i i've got it like the other guy i've
got a background in
java and closure and some other
non-javascript
stuff but i sat with nord for a few
years
did some development in it made sure it
was real i like to think that
architects should actually touch stuff
and make sure that it's valid and it's
workable and things actually do what
they say on the tin
so so i spent about a year with
javascript without node about a year and
a half with node
um i'm competent i guess i can write a
few scripts
but what i found with no which was
really interesting was that
you could run it you all know this but
you can run it in
incredibly uh small environments so what
you don't want to do
is rely on a big fat operating system
underneath
it so if i want to spin up 10 nodes for
instance
then i don't want to be starting up 10
instances of windows
i'd only be starting 10 instances of
linux either
it seems a bit strange to us so we went
we we realized that nord was very
lightweight we wanted to potentially
spin up
lots and lots of instances of them and
so we didn't want to go with something
which was dependent on some very high
cost monolithic operating
system
and i think windows is that i think
microsoft realized that i think they're
getting involved in the docker project
they're getting involved in all kinds of
linux environments on their azure
platform but
windows as a for us if we're going to
get ready for the factory
then i don't like the look of their
factory that factory looks a bit
heavyweight it looks like it's
kind of clunky to start things up so
we want to drop dot net and drop windows
we wanted to drop xml we were using xml
as part of our content management system
but that was burning a hell of a lot of
cpus and
so if you if you you know we didn't we
didn't benchmark this because we just
the cpus on the existing websites were
just always a hundred percent
so i don't need to benchmark that it's
ah
terrible so it's it's quite easy for us
to say okay
let's just stop parsing stuff if we use
json we don't need to parse anything so
that's really nice
uh i didn't need to argue too much about
moving away from a disk
to uh to mongodb because
we'd be getting disk fulls on a weekly
basis so we're getting
disk outages on a weekly basis so that
was quite an easy sell
moving from subversion to git was a
bit of a headache for some people
because they didn't
understand what the benefits of git were
but we worked with the developers to
make them realize that actually pull
requests and
the peer system was a lot more powerful
than the subversion workflow they had at
the time
and we went from a manual deploy to an
automated deploy we use
we use a stack from atlassian
some of you guys might know uh
confluence and jira and they also have
a build system called bamboo and a
git system called stash and
the stash because we're a big
manufacturer and we're scared of
secrets going out of the the world then
out of the world then we we have to have
everything behind the firewall so
our cord and our build systems are
behind the firewall at the moment at
least
and so we use that uh the bamboo and the
stash stuff to do that it supports pull
requests and everything which is uh
very nice so we suddenly get a lot of
visibility into our chord quality
and then we move from these individual
systems out to things like new relic
and log entries on heroku a lot of
add-ons to understand what's going on
within the system suddenly we've got
eyes on the system in a way which we've
never had before
so that's been
we've moved from that kind of sludgy
stuff out to the
uh to this this more automated
environment
uh now so okay where do we build the
factory
um typically we build factories in the
real world where
there is a lot of water a lot of energy
lots of available labor
so where do we build our factory on the
cloud uh
well do we build it on the cloud first
question of course i mean a lot of
people are thinking
okay let's just take a take a stack and
do it internally
the problem with that for us was that we
wanted to say okay we're going to go
this way strategically
and if we do it like that then
unfortunately
or fortunately with toyota you have to
build a lot of consensus
and that's that's good because if you're
doing things together then you're doing
things in
a strong way um but that means that
to do this on premise to do it properly
on premise would require a lot of
investment
and the startup cost of making an
internal cloud
is quite high you have to buy a lot of
hardware you have to get a data center
you have to invest in training people up
in how to run that cloud so
actually it turns out from a timeline if
nothing else
we couldn't afford to do that for this
project something that we're
considering for future projects but an
on-premise cloud at the moment wasn't
possible
so we decided to go off premise now we
do need
to be aware that or you maybe need to be
aware that toyota is a global
corporation
has relationships with lots of different
companies
so we have relations with microsoft and
amazon
we're using amazon all over the place
and we wanted to do a comparison then
between
essentially those three big flavors uh
heroku azur
amazon some other smaller players like
engine yard
joint google app engine openshift um
that was more the on-site stuff so why
did we go
with heroku rather than those other two
big guys
mostly it was because we wanted a true
platform as a service that we could
adopt quite easily
we wanted to build something which
was unaware of its infrastructure
so if we deployed node.js to heroku
then it would be unaware of the fact
that it's going to heroku with azure it
would be a bit more
aware of it because it would be on
windows if you go with azure on linux
you don't get the platform as a service
amazon has this thing called beanstalk
which can do
java and node.js and docker and these
other things
but again amazon is really an
infrastructure service company
does that very well as it's moved up to
platform as a service there's a few gaps
there
so for instance the tooling around the
amazon web services
isn't as strong as the tooling around
things like azure actually or heroku or
these other guys
because amazon's apis if you ever look
at them there's like a thousand apis
everything is a rest api
and it's and from that sense it's really
good if you're a tool builder actually
if you're heroku
then it's really fantastic because you
have a platform to do that but as
a as a kind of shop where we're trying
to essentially outsource this activity
again it would be an extra cost for us
to manage that
the the other thing that we liked about
it was the fact that
there's a lot of ecosystem around heroku
um we could make add-ons
we could add mongodb we could add
elastic search
just push a button the add-on comes and
configure an environment variable start
consuming or start pushing
to that database or to that search
engine so that's really nice
um what we've leveraged also with heroku
is the fact that
they do have uh platform apis like like
amazon but that platform api is quite
small
you can we have a system for instance
that uses node to deploy applications
from one environment to another
environment uh
the other interesting thing about heroku
is that it's an open source build
platform i don't know what the code is
for
for beanstalk i know what the code is
for azure but i know what the code is to
deploy
node.js on heroku i can go to the github
repository i can see what they're doing
and if i don't like it i can change it
in fact we built we built
our own build pack for nginx
to include some google page speed
functionality
uh so that's really an advantage uh that
we
that we found with heroku was that if we
didn't like their build packs we could
change them in fact we just use the
vanilla node.js package
but we have added some others
we can deploy in europe as well most
these guys can deploy in europe
so that's good but the fact that we can
keep our data in europe helps
regulations and helps
people from being too scared about
putting stuff that the nsa can see
although to be honest the nsa looking at
websites
that's okay it's another hit um
the other thing i liked about heroku uh
was that coming back to that kind of
monolithic operating system model
uh is that heroku has some early
insights into linux containers
so everyone's awash with docker now
everyone's kind of
happy about docker and and microsoft
even
and google and all those guys are all
getting into docker
as the basis for a platform as a service
but heroku is already there so they're
already using these um
these linux containers and they have a
nice document called 12-factor
it's a website which gives you all the
kind of architectural
guidelines you should follow which
helped us to prepare for the factory
the other thing that and again i don't
know how many of you guys are from big
enterprises but
if you if you look at these smaller
companies like engine yard or joint
then it's a difficult cell to say okay
uh i've got this thing called node.js
and i want to run it on this platform
called
uh engine yard and the executives at
least now a company are like
huh what's node uh i haven't heard of
this engine yard is
isn't that where we scrap our vehicles
they just don't understand so i could
say instead
actually we want to deploy on this thing
called heroic when it's owned by
salesforce we already have a global
partnership with them
okay ticker box move along so
essentially i could come in under the
radar which was
which was pretty cheeky but it all
worked out
uh i'll give you a little bit of an
insight into how we run
our operations now uh
i can't we don't literally go to italy
and deploy two applications or go to
spin and deploy to applications
uh over with a helicopter what we do is
we have
uh i mentioned at the beginning i
actually i
think my my friend there i mentioned the
beginning we have this monolithic
application on site
and on site we have one app or one
cluster of apps
that serve the rest the whole of the
europe and
what we do now instead is we have
an application which we can clone and
deploy out
on a per nation basis or a per-market
basis
that's actually turned out to be really
good for us because
we can then go to places like
we can we can try things out on markets
like
portugal or bulgaria or azerbaijan i
said by shout outs about three visitors
a week so we can try a few things out
there make sure it works
we've got a couple of dinos over there
and then we can say okay right now let's
roll it out to greece that's right out
to portugal
or we can take a bigger risk and we can
say let's make a change on the french
website
and it's isolated only to the french
market
and that's really helped us because in
the past we've been struck with these
disc fulls or these out of memory errors
or if we lose a machine in the cluster
we're suddenly down to 60 percent of our
capacity
with this system instead we can just say
okay if there's a particular campaign
going on in
poland or russia or finland or whatever
we can just turn up the dinos for that
market
either manually or through some
automated system
and that's what i would call
manufacturing these websites
so we're going
more and more towards that model of
having everything dedicated towards a
particular
marketplace from the top to the bottom
so the web server
the the middleware in the node the
databases everything all the way down
the stack
um at the moment we still have some
things that are uh on premise and that
are kind of monolithic
and we're breaking those out as we
gradually break those out we're
following the same model
and this is really a key thing for us is
the ability for us to
spin up lots of different clones of the
same application in many different
markets
and we know that they all they're all
going to behave pretty much the same way
but we can configure them going forward
as well so for instance if
the italy guys want to integrate with
their dealer management systems or their
order management systems
then we can have a special environment
variable or special add-on
that plugs into their application that
doesn't plug into the other markets
so this is really a powerful option for
us
i've kind of run out of steam so i'm i'm
done a little bit early
so i would be happy if we could take a
few questions
any questions
can i ask how is the workflow been are
people like for people at toyota have
were they had they used because i know
for example for me
uh most of my work uh that i've ever
done with hiroku has been really like
uh hobbyist and so for me it's like if i
wanna something just wanna spin it up
don't worry about it just go to heroku
but like
for you guys had you had engineers who
had experience with the platform already
and did that help with transition
we had no experience with the platform
at all okay um
it was i mean and that's that's really
the good thing about it because
i had a discussion actually with the cio
last week about it and he was saying oh
yeah but in the end you need to
log on to these machines you need to get
into this platform as a service you know
you can't just buy these platforms
you've got to go and really discover
everything about them
which is great for you but you know but
actually it turns out not to be true you
can't actually log on to any of the
machines in heroku you can't literally
touch them they're
it's impossible to touch those things so
we can't fiddle with them
and we can't know exactly what's going
on in there all we know is that we can
run up
exact copies of them and diagnose things
we can
we can get hands-on to them but we
haven't had we haven't got any
um we haven't had any experience
beforehand of the the deep
platform and we haven't really needed it
because actually the surface area of
heroku is quite small
from an engineering perspective
and actually the workflow has been quite
simple the developers are developing in
a completely
heroku has a concept of organizations so
you can have an organization which is a
development organization
for the websites another organization
which is
uh for production so that goes beyond
the kind of hobbyist
they have an enterprise package where
you can set up an organization called
production organization called
development
all the developers can have their roles
and their activities and they can spin
up their dynos
in complete safety in the development
environment when they're ready to go
we have one little program which will
say okay
taking your your uh your dyno your exact
like the docker file or docker image
take your image
out of that development environment and
plunk it exactly into production
so that's the workflow we have in terms
of promotion but the development
workflow is basically just a standard
kind of
do everything on your local machine
using
jetbrains or web id you know whatever
you want to do sublime text
and then push it out to heroku and git
make sure it all works
put it into some testing environment so
the users can check it out and then repo
promoted to production you haven't run
into and not having full control over
the machine as you would otherwise you
have have you run into issues like
uh where you you know it was hard to
install something or when something went
south it was hard to detect or
or mitigate in a way that you that you
wouldn't have if you actually had
physical control as much as you at least
can have in the cloud of that machine
not through heroku uh
this is often the question you get is
that oh you don't you don't control this
stuff right
you know but actually you don't want to
control it you really don't want to
control this stuff
as long as you can get eyes on it you
know so there's dashboards they've got
lots of things like librato
new relic log entries you can you can
inspect what your code is doing and like
i say you can start up an exact copy of
your
of your dyno and you can look into that
you can look into the copy
and if that's not doing the same thing
as production then things are definitely
going south
um but we haven't had any problems like
that we've had a few problems with our
apis
where we've had to talk to the heroku
guys and you know have a support call to
say
we've made a deployment but it doesn't
seem to work for all of these cases
can you help us out that's probably the
only case that's ever really happened
and i think it's happened twice in
in three or four months that's sorry
sorry i have a question what's your
question tim
um we're talking about ourselves so yeah
you can you can also put your hands up
um what are some of the tools that
you're thinking of building in the
future like what what are you excited
about
as far as building to automate all your
heroku processes
i thought you'd ask that one well
there's a few things i mean
we want to build we want to build
basically the tools that we want to
build
around release management now i'm not
sure
i talked to some of the heroku guys as
well they've got plans for
for building release management tools
we have some ideas about what we'd like
to see in those tools and we'll
probably build some ourselves uh but
it's basically about saying okay well
i'd like to know which version of of the
app is in
is in production at the moment across
the entire organization
at the moment we have to go into each
app and have a look at that in detail
and that's a bit annoying
so i'd like to have a dashboard that
could show
the entire production environment i'd
like to also
see for instance why is this one
application different from those
applications if it was
if it was intentional that's great we
did it deliberately
but if it's not intentional then i want
to know about it
uh we have one i think we've time for
one more question uh before we go into
break
um hello i've got not quite technical
question but
i'd like to ask how you uh plan the
budgeting for your
cloud infrastructure if you go to ceo
you have to provide some figures so is
there a tool or something that helps you
so i don't understand can you repeat the
question
well if you have to plan the budget for
your
cloud infrastructure yeah how how would
you
approach that okay you have to do that
actually of course
um so what we did was we said
okay we did some benchmarks not not we
did some benchmarks
to price out the infrastructure
basically we we took the existing
website and we said okay what's the
number of hits we get every month
let's run up a basic version of node run
it on
on a local machine see how many
how many hits we can sustain uh on nord
we ran that on on amazon we ran that on
on heroku as well
and we see okay we there are a bunch of
add-on tools for load testing as well
through heroku and
you can get on the cloud of course so we
run some benchmarks we serve here right
well
this instance of node can can handle
for this country let's say germany
we've got two node.js instances
it can handle this much traffic without
sweating so everything's good
and then we can say okay well germany is
the biggest one of the biggest markets
so everything else will at least match
that so we can go with two dinos
everywhere
at the node.js layer maybe use two dinos
at the engine x layer
and then we can say okay if we've got 30
countries we'll just
cost out there then you're going to pay
for
add-ons like mongodb like elasticsearch
and they're all well priced up front so
you can do those budgets
so in fact it turns out to be relatively
straightforward
with heroku to do that it's more
complicated i think with amazon because
all the component pieces are
quite difficult to all wrapper your head
around and then you find oh actually i
need this i need that i need this
so i would say that from a
of course it's possible to do with
amazon and then we we already use amazon
for a number of things
but we it's more difficult to predict i
think with amazon than with heroku
because it's not so simple
to package those things up so yeah good
question
okay we've hit break time uh so thanks
to
thanks to ray thanks very much